para nadie en este país es un secreto
que en el parlamento peruano existen
intereses políticos y electorales en
torno al adelanto de los comicios muchos
analistas coinciden en que el congreso
se ha puesto de espaldas al Perú porque
existiría falta de voluntad para probar
el adelanto de las elecciones tal como
la presidenta Dina boluarte y la
defensoría del pueblo le han pedido al
poder legislativo priorizar la Reforma
en el más corto plazo para tratar de
obtener una solución democrática que
garantice la paz social y la
tranquilidad de este país en estos
momentos difíciles que ya lleva más de
50 muertos y más de 1500 heridos desde
que se iniciaron las protestas contra
Dina boluarte y en medio de este
contexto el parlamento va a atender una
reconsideración votación el próximo 30
de enero Qué probabilidades existen De
que se apruebe adelantar las elecciones
bueno el panorama es complicado y nada
garantiza que se apruebe el adelanto de
elecciones en ese sentido la principal
razón que se está comentando Es que la
reforma afecta directamente a los
congresistas porque les recorta el
mandato y muchos no quieren dejar el
cargo y entró este escenario existe en
los congresistas de derecha quienes
acusan a la izquierda de entorpecer el
proceso porque están tratando de imponer
la convocatoria a una asamblea
Constituyente la redacción de una nueva
constitución y esto señalan que se debe
a que están siguiendo las órdenes
dirigidas por el expresidente Pedro
castillo y por el lado de la izquierda
acusan a la derecha de
impulsar El adelanto de los comicios
porque señalan que la derecha ya tendría
todo listo para imponerse en el poder y
dentro de todo este escenario político
de conflicto en el parlamento peruano
legisladores quienes oponen a la reforma
de adelanto a elecciones porque
manifiestan que esto no garantiza una
solución a esta crisis política y social
que vive el Perú así las cosas el día
lunes va a haber un debate muy largo y
vamos a ver quizás al fin de la jornada
si es que los congresistas se pusieron
de acuerdo no en aprobar la reforma del
adelanto de las elecciones en este